Jay Leno has just suffered very serious
Burns kind of a hard segue but it
relates very broadly to what we're
talking about here uh Jay Leno as a lot
of people know loves cars he loves
working on his own cars he was working
on one of his cars and he got gasoline
sprayed onto his face and then there was
a spark and his face caught on fire I
mean it just sounds absolutely awful he
was rushed to the hospital he could have
died
easily easily could have died Dr Peter
Grossman who's a board-certified plastic
surgeon in La told reporters that Leno
suffered quote significant Burns to his
face and hands and required a surgical
excision and grafting procedure uh Leno
then told TMZ
that his friend Dave who was in the
garage with him at the time was able to
smother the Flames otherwise it easily
could have killed him and then the
doctor said
that now this is just like a couple of
days later that Leno was in good spirits
and was even helping with the other
patients and giving children cookies
said quote we're very happy to have him
as part of our team
so this guy just gets his face and hands
burnt off and a couple of days later
he's out cracking jokes having a fun
time in the hospital giving kids cookies
a lot of people are asking how can he do
this people probably aren't that
surprised because when you think of Jay
Leno you just think of this very buoyant
guy just like
you know he's always just kind of happy
he's not one of these angry comedians
he's very funny and delightful
a great lesson here
is is on how good it is to cultivate
buoyancy
okay how good it is
to
not only be resilient in the sense that
you're really tough and you can
withstand troubles but to be buoyant
that when that when circumstances get
you down and try to smother you drown
you in the water you just pop right back
up
buoyancy is really really important and
people very often just have the opposite
they'll they'll sink to the bottom even
if they're taking a nice swim in the
Caribbean Ocean you know even if even if
they're in broadly happy circumstances
they'll still find some terrible thing
some negative discomfort to to obsess
about
you don't want to do that people have
this fantasy which is you know I'm
things are tough right now but once I
get past this then I'll be happy uh you
know it's a tough week at work but once
I get past this week at work then then
I'll be happy I'm having a hard time you
know with my family but once once this
one thing changes six months from now
then I'll be happy ah you know the house
needs work oh it's so annoying I got a
leak in my ceiling once we fix that leak
though then I'll be happy and
the people who think that way are never
happy that's the secret because there's
always going to be some other thing
and there's always going to be some
circumstance that is imperfect because
we live in a fallen world
so it is
I think your duty but it's certainly
greatly to your benefit to cultivate
that kind of buoyancy now
circumstances are sort of morally
neutral okay suffering is not a an
immoral thing
so you can respond to suffering in a in
a good moral edifying sanctifying way or
you can respond to it in a degrading and
and
dissatifying way I hate that word
because it's a silly word but you can in
a destructive way in a way that is
really not going to be good for you okay
suffering is just part of the world
and so you'll notice
the people who
the people who can have their face burnt
off and still be happy and buoyant and
able to get by the next day
they're the people who don't sweat the
small stuff either you know it's a it's
not a a fact of circumstance it's a fact
of their own character and I think it's
on all of us to cultivate that
sometimes people will say you see this
in politics they'll say we just we just
need to do X Y and Z and then we'll
finally achieve a good country that's
what we need to achieve a good country
a country is not a thing to achieve
a country is a place to inhabit okay
it's not we're going to get there this
had a progressives talk we're gonna get
there we're not there yet but we're
going to get there where we achieve this
good country we're already there we're
in the country okay we are here
and
every single moment of the day
we have the option to to pursue good and
avoid evil or to pursue evil and avoid
good in all of our little decisions
that's how you have a good country okay
is you just do the right thing
consistently and you cultivate that
habit because virtue is a habit and then
you have a good country
it's not some distant thing six months
from now then we're gonna have a good
country you can do it right now
right now head on over to kamikoto.com
Knowles using techniques that have been
honed and perfected by generations of
bladesmiths kamikoto knives are crafted
only of high quality Japanese steel each
kamikoto knife goes through a rigorous
19-step process that takes several years
from start to finish with more than 100
years of experience between them
kamikoto's expert bladesmiths shape raw
Japanese steel into hearty blades
polishing and sharpening them to an
excruciatingly fine single bevel Edge
the sharp edges why comicoter knives can
cut through Meat and Fish like butter
and why they are used by Michelin rated
chefs around the world each knife is
individually inspected and comes with a
lifetime guarantee plus kamikoto knives
come in a beautiful heavy duty Ash wood
box for safe storage this stunning
presentation makes kamikoto a great gift
during this Christmas season kamikoto is
now running a Black Friday sale and
offering my viewers an additional fifty
dollars off any purchase with discount
code nulls go to kamikoto.com Knowles
and get your knives set and help support
this channel
Mitch McConnell will be re-elected
uh Republican majority or republican
minority leader in the Senate that is
going to happen there was a challenge
from Rick Scott Rick Scott a more
conservative senator from Florida
he challenged McConnell
they held a vote it was it was a secret
ballot because none of the Senators want
to get on cocaine Mitch's bad side
because he's just going to turn out like
Tony Montana you know and pull that
automatic weapon say hello to my little
right so it was a secret ballot Rick
Scott pried away about 10 votes
McConnell gets reelected
and he he told us that this would happen
he said I have the votes I will be
elected the only issue is whether we do
it sooner or later now I don't hate
Mitch McConnell in the way that a lot of
conservatives do because McConnell held
firm on the judges when Scalia died and
McConnell is in large part the reason
why we got to overrule Roe v Wade and
why Trump probably one of the main
reasons Trump got elected to replace
Scalia and then why
we got that big victory in Dobbs so
I like McConnell but the man is not a
hard-line rock ribbed conservative Chuck
Schumer now the Senate Majority Leader
again is already talking about sitting
down with McConnell and trying to kill
off the Maga movement I am going to say
to the Republicans in the Senate who are
not the Maga Republicans stop letting
them lead your party work with us to get
things done and I intend to sit down
with Mitch McConnell and express that
and I think you've been saying that what
are you asking for just quickly when are
you gonna you're sitting down in Mitch
McConnell this week no I'm gonna I
intend I've said this yesterday and the
day before too I intend to sit down with
him and say how can we we should be
working together you're not going to get
the extremists in your party to work
with anybody but the rest of us can work
together and get them some real things
done for the American people
so thankfully CNN clarified here and
said wait when are you sitting down with
Mitch McConnell and he said no I intend
to so it's not like they have a meeting
on the books but I'm sure McConnell will
be more than open to these
this Overture from Schumer
McConnell hates the Maga wing of the
party there's no question about that
the GOP establishment in Washington DC
hates the Maga wing of the party
and
this is why
just as we talk about healthy skepticism
when we hear reports out of the war in
Ukraine we need healthy skepticism when
we hear reports out of why the
Republicans did or did not perform in
the midterms
the people who hate Donald Trump and the
Maga movement
are going to be much more inclined to
blame the disappointing performance on
during the midterms on Trump and the
Maga movement
almost to a man the people who are
blaming this thing on Trump didn't like
Trump to begin with and don't like the
Maga movement
now if you talk to the mega movement
people and the people who like Donald
Trump
they're going to be much more inclined
to blame
the upending of our voting rules for
what happened on Tuesday
they're going to say yeah we had a red
wave in Florida and maybe you can say
that's only because of DeSantis but how
do you explain the Red Wave in Texas how
do you explain the Red Wave in Ohio how
do you explain the difference between
Florida Texas and Ohio and Arizona and
Nevada
well the difference there is that
Florida Texas and Ohio had tightened up
their voting rules and they didn't even
tighten them up all that much but they
tightened them up a little bit after
2020. Arizona and Nevada did not there
were a whole lot of shenanigans that we
saw in Arizona and Nevada and surprise
surprise the Republicans lose
so if you look at it from that Vantage
which I think is much more persuasive
then the question is not over candidate
quality or those crazy Maga candidates
JD Vance was a crazy Mega candidate he
won just fine
wasn't just oh you know it's Blake
Masters and Carrie like they're crazy
Maga candidates there it would seem that
the more decisive Factor
was the election
laws
that the changing to the way that we
conduct the elections which give a huge
benefit to the Democrats the majority of
votes coming in early as a result of
things like ballot harvesting right
that's obviously going to favor
Democrats Republicans don't have a
ballot harvesting
organization we just don't have it at
all Democrats have had them for decades
maybe that's
maybe that's really what's going on here
I just would urge caution as when you
read the news about Ukraine urge caution
and and maybe notice every now and again
that the people who are so insistent
this is exactly what happened very often
it's the people who got all their
predictions wrong about the elections
but then the next day they're going to
go on air and tell you this is exactly
what happened who have no epistemic
humility whatsoever here they're they're
going to say
that just coincidentally
what happened in my analysis of the
elections what happened is
every single thing to confirm my own
priors yeah okay I'm a little skeptical
of that I don't think so I don't think
that we should accept the establishment
line maybe we don't even necessarily
accept the the mega line of argument at
face value maybe we look into these
things for ourselves and recognize it's
a complex process there's a lot at play
and there are a lot of forces who are
fighting a long simmering Civil War that
actually has nothing to do with the
midterms and it's been going on for a
very very long time I will be hosting a
panel right now in the member block
of women
of good-looking normal women from around
the country to explain to me the appeal
of ski Davidson the rest of the show
continues now you don't want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]